Let's continue our discussion
of specialized defenses
where a long history of
selection has caused natural selection
to shape a particular response to a
particular environmental insult.
The inflammatory response is activated
both by infection and by injury.
There are specialized cells in the immune
system that coordinate inflammation
and inflammation maintains both
tissue integrity and homeostasis.
Those cells,
the macrophages and the mass cells detect
the noxious stimuli and they produced
inflammatory mediators, which
are cytokines, chemokine,
biogenic amines,
leukotrienes and prostaglandins.
So there is a mix of chemicals that
are secreted and act is signals to
coordinate this response.
The C fiber nociceptors,
the pain receptors produce neuropeptides
to elicit a local inflammatory response
to tissue injury and at the
expense of normal functions.
These mediators act on the target tissues
inducing changes that defend against
the noxious stimulus.
The inflammatory mediators produce
proteins that are involved in defense,
in blood clotting,
tissue repair that suppress proteins
that are involved in normal homeostasis.
And that changed the homeostatic set
points for body temperature and for
appetite.
Yeah,
these symptoms of sickness
then result fever,
anorexia, fatigue, social
withdrawal, sleepiness,
and decreased sex drive.
So the inflammatory response coordinates
a defense reaction across a series of
levels from inside sales to communicating
between cells to whole organism
behavior.
Yeah,
inflammation is quite costly.
There are many changes induced by acute
inflammation that are the opposite of
the fight or flight response,
but some of them overlap.
Inflammatory mediators suppress growth
and reproduction and the override homo
homeostatic controls, so that allocation
goes towards survival functions.
Inflammation is a high benefit trait
that permits high costs in trade offs and
vulnerabilities.
Acute inflammation can result
in collateral damage and
even an organ failure at
the extreme.
This dysregulated acute inflammation
can be deadly as for example,
in septic shock, which results
from infections in the blood.
Dysregulated inflammation can also lead
to diseases of homeostasis that are
often elicited by mismatch
such as type two diabetes.
Allergic defenses are
another specialized defense.
They operate in barrier tissues of the
upper respiratory, gastrointestinal,
and urogenital tract.
They respond to noxious substances
such as venoms and irritants.
The main defenses expel the substances
and reinforced the barriers.
So there's mucus production,
runny nose, airway obstruction.
I have a bit of that right now.
Bronco constriction to prevent
further exposure, sneezing,
coughing, vomiting and diarrhea to get
the noxious substances out of the body.
Itching to remove
substances from the skin.
Yeah,
so these defenses have high costs and
produce significant discomfort and that
discomfort protects by
inducing behavioral avoidance.
The discomfort teaches us
to avoid these situations,
runny nose and vomiting,
both ways of getting noxious
substances out of the body.
The detoxification response,
a specialized defense is used when we've
been exposed to toxic environmental
chemicals and they elicit a different
kind of protective response.
This response is based on metabolic
modification and excretion of noxious
chemicals and much of it is mediated
by two gene families that you are now
already familiar with.
Those that are coding for NSF,
he'll transfer races and ATS and
Cytochrome p four 50s see why peas?
This is an ancient defense system system.
It protects from the harmful
effect of reactive chemicals.
It presumably evolve to defend us against
phytochemicals which plants use to
defend themselves against herbivores
and the modern world.
This is the system that
provides protection from
industrial pollutants and from
toxic drug metabolites.
Yeah.
Define detoxification of metabolic
byproducts is conceptually distinct from
defense against environmental insults,
but the two are making this
Stickley and evolutionarily related.
Essentially an ancient system used to
defend us against nasty substances made by
plants,
is used in the modern world,
both to defend us against industrial
pollutants and other environmental insults
and also the process drugs.
Yeah.
The innate immune response to infection
is our first line of defense against
pathogens.
It is defending us against microbial
infections and detects infection by
recognizing conserved microbial
products such as lipopolysaccharides and
peptidoglycan hands that are unique
and that are essential to microbes.
So these molecules are a signal that a
microbe is present and they are not made
by cells in our body.
They can therefore be discriminated from
self and they ensure that pathogens do
not evolve.
Escape units,
which would be crippled by the
laws of essential molecules.
So the innate immune system is looking
for things that are unique to microbial
pathogens and that microbial
pathogens cannot do without.
Yeah.
It can also detect infection indirectly
by sensing the activities of virulence
factors,
toxins and allergens.
Innate immune recognition
rapidly activates the
inflammatory response signaled
here by conjunctivitis in of patient's
eye and other antimicrobial mechanisms
including Phagocytosis,
the compliment system,
a system of proteins that coats,
uh,
pathogens and aids immune cells
in recognizing and digesting them,
natural killer cells and
anti bacterial defense.
So the antibacterial defensins are
proteins that are secreted and the innate
immune response also has
natural killer cells,
which are a part of the immune system
that is not triggered by the adaptive
immune response. These are all things
that can be ramped up fairly quickly.
The innate immune system determines
the origin of an antigen. That is,
whether it is a virus and extra
or intracellular bacterium,
or you carry out like a
fungus or something like
malaria or the sleepy sickness
pathogen or a worm and it produces a
corresponding signal so it identifies the
kind of pathogen and signals then
the adaptive immune system system.
That's why it is essential for activating
the adaptive immune responses because
those immune responses differ
with the type of pathogen.
The adaptive immune system is
mediated by T and B lymphocytes.
T means that they've
matured in the thymus.
B means they matured in the bone marrow.
Okay.
And the adaptive immune response is
an extremely powerful defense system.
It uses antigen receptors,
antibodies that are generated at random
by somatic recombination gene and random
pairing of receptor subunits.
So these different genetic mechanisms
take the genetic heterogeneity,
which is stored in families
of these genes in our,
in our genome and recombine them and
associate them with particular clones of t
and B cells.
It's capable of making millions of
antigen receptors and one of them will be
able to recognize any attitude
lymphocytes with antigen
receptors specific for
microbial antigens are selected
them to proliferate.
This is the clonal selection process,
generating clones of effective
of effector memory cells.
So this is a way of ramping up a very
specific response by growing a huge
population of cells,
all of which are devoted
to one particular antigen,
which is associated with
a particular pathogen.
Because the antigen
receptors are made at random,
they cannot determine the
origin of the antigens,
whether that's self tissue,
microbial pathogen,
or some innocuous environmental antigen.
They must therefore be kept from
reacting inappropriately to self and to
harmless environmental antigens.
So it's a very powerful system,
but it contains a
vulnerability because of it.
It reacts with inappropriate tissue.
It can cause autoimmune pathologies.
This is the structure of an antibody.
It is a y shaped molecule
protein molecule.
It has a fairly cause.
It has a constant region with a heavy
chain and a constant region and the light
chain and the action is going on out
here at the tips where you have the
variable region of the light chain and
the variable region of the heavy chain.
And these are the segments which exist
are being produced by genes that are
highly polymorphic and they can be
recombined to generate particular binding
regions that will recognize
particular antigens.
Now one of the powerful features of
the adaptive immune response is that it
creates a memory so that
after an initial exposure,
the host can then be protected
from subsequent effects,
infections coming from the same pathogen
and that allows subsequent responses to
ramp up more quickly.
And this is the basis of vaccinations.
So vaccination induces the production of
a clone of cells that will be ready to
react the next time the organism
sees that particular antigen.
Vaccines Mimic infections and they produce
then this immunological memory that
will protect.
Okay.
The defenses are modifications
of processes that operate
normally in the absence
of a stressor might seem less
obvious for immune defense,
the detoxification
response and tissue repair.
But in all of these cases,
there is a non defensive counterpart.
The immune system manages the Microbiota
and it manages tissue homeostasis.
Okay.
There is metabolic regulation for
the diff detoxification system,
and in the case of tissue repair,
there was tissue renewal.
So in all of these cases,
the defense system is evolutionarily
derived from a part of normal physiology.
Yeah.
The exaggeration of each type of defense
produces a characteristic associated
disease.